attenzione ciò che state per vedere in
questo video è frutto della poca sanità
mentale è rimasta marcone remo si prega
di non imitare
da dove posso cominciare allora io e
marco siamo amici no nel senso che ogni
tanto vado a trovare come sta come non
stai
insomma l'altro giorno sono andato a
casa sua e mi fa lorenzo
voglio fare una foto su instagram lui fa
dei contenuti un po particolari no c'è
fate le cose un po strane c'è si ricopre
di cioccolata fa cosa insomma
l'università per avere un'opzione nella
mia vita
lui voleva fare una foto su instagram
dove voleva diventare un candelabro
quindi ha comprato delle candele affuso
della cera e voleva attaccarsi sulla
pancia e le candele con la cera calda
tutto questo per una foto di instagram
cioè non è che doveva riprenderla sta
roba una foto per fare una foto ho detto
no vabbè non posso non documentarla
quindi toledo marco soffri to monetizzò
io vidi io monetizza le sofferenze di
marko marin vi lascio al documentario
che state per me perché di animali si
parla insomma è buona visione
salve sono marco marino
siamo qua a casa mia voglio diventare un
candelabro le madri milioni di al tavolo
che vuole la vita sei del fantastico
minimi o diventare un candela ma perde
per un candelabro bisogna avere intanto
il canto questo sarà questo è il benfica
alzare il suo figlio il candelabro che
ci voleva cambiate per attaccare attack
troppo dossi lo scotch non va bene le
trash c'era e ognuno di noi dovrà avere
due candele in mano
è stata così analisi minuti si chiama
abbastanza lasciamo grazia mostrandola
proviene per la roba della foto di
questa roba è per fare una foto di vista
che non si versa della roba per una foto
si sta che non monetizza neanche si sta
roba c'è monetizzò io con il suo dolore
cosi di candele se siete interessati a
questo business
chiamatemi fa veramente ma anche perché
la pancia è molto sensibile
un sacco di nardi ma io non riuscirei a
fare neanche così col dito come fai due
rinnovata e più sole al tecnico primo e
quindi noi siamo il mignolo che sono
perdono cose mai al peggio al minimo
anche avanti col problema mi chiama io
non esco a farlo col dito te lo giuro
gago in mano a far colorare di mensa e
sopportabile ma fa male è sopportabile
ma fa male comunque sicuramente sulla
pancia e non lo farei mai questo passo
sicuro ci vediamo poco ultimamente è
arrivato pietro non sa niente ricordare
qualcosa
poi ognuno di noi avrà una candela a
curarla bene aiutava pronzato iene preso
abbiamo creato un cadelago come stai per
una foto pietro vorrei un attimo
blizzard che tazzer su simbolo del
carattere devi stare attento perché se
arriva ci farà malissimo
prima di mettere fra parentesi ma
aspetta una trackball e che mi ha detto
voglio mettere lo so come mettiamo la
candela chi ascoltava anche il mio via
ok e mettiamole genere una pezza in
botto l'acqua c'è un calzino
da cannes firme bellissimi brani come le
due milioni i francesi ragazza ma non
massimo ce n'è ancora
basta turisti professor scettico il
cazzo di foto a sin
dimmi tu calabrò aspetto che è un po più
freddo però stai sudan ma è tutto ok
bros titoletti satana di scusarmi sullo
storico
non voglio dire al signor che si rompa
al tumore ma mia madre mia terra mi è
mai fregato come silente ma no vino vino
mamma mia è stato lorenzo vero abbiamo
finito in teoria la metti non conosco è
finita adesso è finito
ti senti un pò lumiere marco che si vede
che un fulmine o perché vuoi togliere ma
che abbiamo è quella delle candele la
programmate giornate ragazzi se volete
fare cosplay particolari di alcuni
personaggi disney chiamate a me ma come
è ora domani st ciao riesco con un renzo
si giurano vista novate residenti questa
roba non in chiave la bellissima un
aspetto più pc chi è più vicino al
compleanno sia più vicino al compleanno
poi esprimere non che ammazzi malco una
volta che le tolgo la fa malissimo a
vedersi diversi si arriva piccola torna
c'era viaggio al centro della terra o
poi il trucco di alien ma allora ragazzi
adesso io vado in bagno ci vediamo frase
dice niente
e stato bello
[Musica]